but my first point is is this
congressman you know I watched the
interview and I was stunned it took my
breath away as James Comey talked about
the dossier well it could have happened
the bulk of information to obtain that
warrant to spy on an American
Association in an election year was the
dossier and if it wasn't for you and
your committee we never would have
learned that or the Grassley Graham memo
that came out do you think it's what
does that mean about what they said to a
FISA Court the irony here is is quite
frankly hard to believe you know some of
the language that mr. Comey uses like he
says well it's currently or he I think
he said it was it's certainly possible
that the Russians had information on
Trump well it's certainly possible it's
certainly possible that the Russians
could have information on Comey it's
certainly possible that the Russians
could have information on Hillary
Clinton it's certainly possible
information on all kinds of people when
that dossier which made up the bulk of
the FISA application and subsequent
three renewal applications if it's
possible and it wasn't verified and it
wasn't corroborated and you still
presented it to a judge and you never
told the judge that Hillary paid for it
bought and paid for it and that it was a
foreign national that printed salacious
unproven lies from Russian sources did
they lie to a FISA Court judge in your
opinion well by not telling the FISA
Court it's totally inappropriate because
they knew the information and they have
a duty an obligation to tell the court
everything that they know but Sean let's
go back also to when we were first
briefed about the dossier we Congress so
we heard and mr. commis interview what
he said what what President Trump's
reaction was to learning about the
dossier and he talked about why he
didn't tell President Trump that it was
paid bought paid for by his political
opponents well there's other people that
are important in this like the United
States Congress I was in the meeting
with Senator McConnell with leader
McConnell with the Speaker of the House
Paul Ryan and many others where he had
ample opportunity in early 2017 to tell
us who paid for the dossier we were
briefed on the dossier and I can tell
you if if they would have brought up if
the FBI would have presented to us on
that day that this information was paid
for by the Democratic Party and then
Hughes or forget the fact that it was
even used in the FISA and wasn't
verified but but wasn't verified and
will he we knew it wasn't verified at
the time because they told us that it
wasn't verified okay but can you imagine
the reaction first of all I think I
would have spit up my coffee and started
laughing but secondly we would have
walked out of there we would have said
what in the hell are you guys doing
you're bringing us dirt that the Hillary
Clinton campaign paid for you guys have
been using this and you're now
presenting it to us as to you know why
you have concerns about the Trump
campaign I feel that this is probably
one of the if not the biggest
abuse of power that I've ever seen in my
entire life and when you then go back to
and you see that you know these these
same players keep coming up and it was
Comey with Trump aiding Peters struck we
still haven't gotten all the text
messages and then Peter struck is the
one that interviews Hillary and Peter
struck in James Comey are writing an
exoneration in May and they don't
interview her till July it seems to me
that that investigation was rigged sir
or or let's just to throw another one in
there you have this mr. Comey
volunteered this up on in the interview
the other day he said that the end of
the FISA the FISA on Carter page Carter
page wasn't the initial way the reason
that they started the investigation it
was Papadopoulos okay so you you wanted
to investigate Papadopoulos you had
concerns about Papadopoulos just for
your viewers that was in July of 2016
well why is it that you never bothered
to talk to mr. Papadopoulos but you did
bother to go and get a FISA warrant on
mr. page and
October of sixteen you don't talk to
Papadopoulos until 2017
well wait a second I thought
Papadopoulos was the reason you started
the investigation in the first place so
these are all unanswered questions it
keeps unraveling on them but we have to
keep fighting well we need David right
if I bit we need the information I'm
gonna give it motion this hall needs to
go to court and people need to be held
in contempt of Congress and I agree with
you on the second special counsel all
right congressman we appreciate your
hard work always a pleasure